Speaker 1: All right.
We're being super thorough today.
We already looked at our correspondent Luke
Beazley's interviews on the ground in Miami
just to prove to everyone that Luke wasn't
hand selecting or cherry picking the craziest
people.
Let's take just a little bit of a tour through
what we saw yesterday on corporate media,
for example.
Fox News was also out there doing interviews.
I guess this is actually Fox Business and
they found a completely deranged guy.
This guy is as deranged as anybody Luke found.
The conspiracy theory this gentleman has is
that Hunter Biden started the war in Ukraine
and that he actually started it five years
ago.
This is not us now.
This is not Luke Beazley cherry picking.
This is Fox business's Griff Jenkins.
Speaker 2: Country, the most innocent man
that's ever been in the White House.
Donald J. Trump the best president we've ever
had.
45 slash 47.
He's coming back.
This is the longest witch hunt going on eight
years now since he came down the escalator.
You're going the guy's an American hero.
Do you believe there's a two tier system of
justice?
Do you believe this is unfair?
Obviously, I don't even know how anybody can
ask that with a straight face.
There's obviously a two tiered justice system.
Why is the Clinton crime family running wild?
Why is Beijing Biden and the money laundering
operation that Hunter Biden started out of
Ukraine?
He started the war on Ukraine five years ago
when he was working for Burisma.
Speaker 1: None of this is true, but I know
I know most of you know that.
Speaker 2: If you go back to the last question,
if Trump were to get reelected, should he
consider a pardon for the Biden family?
Absolutely not.
Their crime family.
You're there an American or a.
Speaker 5: Democrat these days.
There's no way to be both.
Speaker 1: All right.
That's just as crazy as anybody that we were
able to find.
I mean, just absolutely no distinction.
We had Luke's interview earlier in the show
with the screaming Cuban woman.
Here is what this is a local station, LFA
TV.
They found a crazy screaming Cuban woman with
many of the same ideas.
We'll talk a little bit about the Cuban-American
community and the context here in a moment.
Okay.
Speaker 2: Right, Wolf, It doesn't go around
the world, you know, getting money like the
Clintons, like your mama died, all of this
sort of preaching communism.
Speaker 1: This woman's also holding a beer
for people who aren't watching and are only
listening.
Speaker 2: Look where they even know what
they look like.
Might our people live?
They have become rich.
Do you think they care about Hispanics?
Do you think they care about black Americans?
No, they don't date any great on day one of
the guy crossing the border.
Do you think about the charges that these
charges are nothing?
Biden and the State Department when Daniel
Ortega jail all the political opponents was
the first one to condemn that.
He goes around the world preaching about democracy.
How about honesty, when what moral authority
is doing that, when he's doing exactly what
he's been doing in Nicaragua?
Hugo Sandinistas.
Nothing reminds me more of the Sandinista
Now, the way that the Democrats are operating
in this country, there's no separation of
powers.
They're not treating Republicans the way that
they treated Democrats.
If we protest for what they're doing to their
children's, they call us terrorists.
They think we are that are terrorists.
And we are passionate because I lost one nation.
Speaker 1: Okay, so there's another minute
of this.
I won't subject you to that.
There is actually a broader thing here.
I've spoken to many of you before as an Argentinean
American myself about how the vast majority
of Hispanic Americans, folks from Central
and South America, the vast majority of us
are indeed on the left.
There are some notable exceptions, primarily
Cuban Americans and Venezuelan Americans or
Cubans and Venezuelans who just came to the
U.S. from those countries.
And it is a tough situation because many of
these folks truly did flee horrifying regimes
in Cuba and in Venezuela.
There is no doubt about that.
They are right to be angry at and critical
of the regimes that have done so much damage
in those countries.
The problem is, after they flee those broken
countries, they view anything as like if you're
to the left of John McCain or Chris Christie,
essentially you are full blown communist danger.
And it is an unfortunate thing.
It seems as though the Cuban-Americans or
Cubans that we've heard from today certainly
are suffering from that.
And it is certainly a sad situation.
Okay.
Trump then went to a Cuban restaurant.
He was sullen and he had his arms crossed
in court.
Then he went straight to the.
Miami Cuban restaurant Vici, which I may have
been to before, although I don't I don't totally
remember, would have been about 12 years ago.
And in this restaurant, it's just a complete,
you know, cult fest.
They start singing Happy Birthday to Trump.
Trump's birthdays today.
Yesterday was the day before his birthday.
Speaker 3: What a great.
Unidentified: How do you manage?
Speaker 1: 37 felony counts.
Let's sing the guy.
Happy birthday, then, in a completely surreal
Kafka esque moment.
Supposed faith leaders prayed over Trump.
There's a guy with a kippah or yarmulke, depending
on your preference.
He, I believe, is a Cuban Jew.
And he you will hear him do a little bit of
prayer in Hebrew and then switch to Spanish.
As reminiscent and nostalgic as this is for
me, hearing the Hebrew mixed in with the Spanish.
This is pretty horrifying stuff.
Faith leaders at the Cuban restaurant praying
over Trump.
Speaker 6: I if you look at the opening bell.
Speaker 1: Here in Spanish there, he's asking
God to protect this man with all and total
strength.
Speaker 6: I'll give you an example.
If you look at the national level that if
you.
Speaker 1: Give him strength in his hands.
Speaker 3: And you.
Speaker 1: Give him strength in his body,
he says 30.
Speaker 6: A that then it'll mean you're probably
not going to feel the on.
Speaker 1: In the name of Jesus.
The audio was a little muddled there.
Speaker 2: And I thought my.
I'm an American.
Speaker 1: And I'm an okay.
So that that happened.
And then Trump announcing everybody having
a grand old time that he's buying food for
everybody.
Speaker 3: Are you ready?
Are you ready?
Food for everyone.
Food for.
Speaker 1: All right.
I would make sure to get a credit card upfront.
That is for damn sure.
So a crazy day in Miami.
But even if the average maggot maggot potassium
in maggot donation is not abandoning Trump,
increasingly Republican elected officials
are.
Let's discuss
that next.